everyone this is Steve on Trobe with
Collider and I am here with Sean Astin
you are in studio today to promote your
new Netflix show no-goodnik hello there
it's good to be here promoting
no-goodnik yes today's the premiere day
if you just dropped the first 10
episodes dropped today I have so many
questions for you right about know good
Nick but I have to start with I think
the most the most important question
which is you got into acting at a very
young age I did and it is very rare for
child stars to make the transition to
being successful adults without like
drug problems and I'm making sort of a
generalization that's a fair
generalization but you you made the
transition yeah and it's it's a very low
number statistically that can do it what
do you tribute that success to being
pizza I was gonna make a drug joke but
that's terrible no um you know I I think
that my what my father John Astin who
played Gomez in the Addams Family when
we were when I was auditioning for The
Goonies he we worked together and the
thing that he really wanted to impress
upon me at that moment was not to act to
just try and be as real as possible to
be as truthful as possible and with that
as a kind of guiding principle I think
it's the potential for longevity is is
there because then no matter what age
you're at whatever you're doing if
you're doing it as honestly and
authentically as you can if you're
searching for the truth in it then it'll
feel valid and and that that's not
age-specific so you know obviously a
work ethic my mother taught me a good
work ethic when I was a kid I was very
ambitious so probably the hardest parts
of my career when it was uncertain what
would happen I was really you know all
over my agents and managers and
sometimes would change an agent or
change a manager and I would call them
all the time and I was a really you know
I really hustled there was a period of
time where I really really hustled hard
so that had something to do with it my
education was important to me I'm sure
that has something to do with longevity
I've been married almost 30 years in
married 27 years the stability that
comes from that
I'm sure helps with longevity I don't
really you know I don't know that
there's any any one thing but from a
performance perspective from an acting
perspective what allows you to give a
performance at 12 and again I'm 48 now
it's trying to be honest and when I
studied with one of the great acting
teacher Stella Adler for a very brief
period of time her master class she
would say over and over again and she
was 91 years old it is the actor's job
to tell the truth on stage and I think
you know people think acting is
make-believe or pretend but the best
acting is to be as real as possible it's
so funny you bring up Stella Stella
Adler because I absolutely was going to
ask you about and it is there's not too
many people left who can say that they
actually studied under her yeah do you
know what I mean yeah
what do you so how long did you get to
work with her and I took her master
class Milton justice is a guy who was I
don't know if he was artistic director
of the conservatory or if he was he was
just very very close to Stella and
helped her throughout her the later part
of her teaching career he was a producer
who won an Oscar for a movie about
transvestites and transsexuals in the
early 80s he produced the movie I was in
he became a mentor to me and so he kind
of it was it was at a time eighteen
years old I went and made a movie called
Memphis Belle and when I got back from
Memphis Belle it was pretty clear to me
that I wasn't just going to be able to
be you know a guy who was comfortable in
front of a camera
you'd have to develop some sort of
technique or or you know system for
approaching your work and and so he I
took some classes there and when Stella
came from New York and taught a master
class I was there I was only in front of
her one time but I I saw her saw her
teach probably a dozen times maybe a
little more than that and it was it was
a an electrifying experience because you
know when she had such a reputation as a
legend in the American theater and a
legend as a as a teacher that when you
have that expectation for somebody you
put that level of intensity and an
expectation then when the person walks
onto the stage and she would sit on the
stage
just off to the side with a little desk
and she would watch the performances and
most of the time she would stop the
performances and then give her lecture
from there you know if the person's
worthy they rise to the expectation and
there were was a 99 seat house it's now
the theater is now a tram stop at the
ala trip but um you know it was people
were just packed down the aisles and in
the back and and just trying to soak up
every little kernel of energy and
comment you know and and thinking that
she had to offer
are you watching Barry I haven't started
Barry yet but I saw my first like full
scene of Barry was last night actually
and he looks blow away I mean he looks
absolutely incredible I was gonna say
that Henry Winkler plays a acting coach
oh yeah I was gonna but that's a sidebar
let's jump into why you actually why get
to talk today what was it about this
material what was it about the show that
said I want to what excited you about it
the genre I was excited about doing a
sitcom a half hour
you know multicam in front of a live
studio audience that's something that
you know my mother Patty Duke had the
Patty Duke show which was a big hit
multicam in the in the 60s she actually
broke some ground playing identical of
cousins and and that was a big deal my
dad John Astin did the Goma played gomez
in the the Addams Family which wasn't a
proscenium show but it was it was you
know a hit comedy in that era and then
my little brother Mackenzie did many
years on the facts of life and so I sort
of I always all through the 90s I would
book these pilots and then none of them
ever went anywhere
you know these a half-hour sort of first
episodes to see if the studio or the
network would pick them up and they
never did so it was just one that when I
saw this one come through you know I was
actually doing my first play ever I was
doing the first play I've ever done in
the Catskills in Ellenville at the
Shadowlands Festival Shadowlands not
shed on festival Shadowland theatre and
it was a John Cleese play it was a
French farce that he had adapted from
fado
the French
playwright satirist who sort of
developed the the the forest genre and
then in 1899 1900 whatever and it was
incredible it was we were Hirst for
three weeks it was the most terrifying
thing I've ever done more dialog than
all the movies I've been in put together
and I just loved it and I actually got
the call hey they want you for this but
you have to come out an audition they
need to see if you can you know do the
do the Cutlass that come rhythm if you
can do the comedy timing so I flew out
and and did the audition the the young
let's see to our two kids Loren dances
and Kalama up steam and where's Nick
there yeah Sienna algodón who plays Nick
they were there at my audition they
already have the job so they were
essentially there to help me test and
they were they've all done sitcoms
before Nickelodeon Disney or whatever
and I haven't seen their shows but
they're popular I know they're popular
and they help me get the job basically
and you know we gave each other big hugs
and they knew the rhythms of what was
expected of them Suzanne the the casting
director had worked with them to within
an inch of their lives and she worked
with me she called me on a phone in in
New York and we talked for like an over
an hour
describing what was there and when I got
there she worked with me and I would say
something that you know do like this do
it like this do it like this she wanted
me to get the part but they were looking
for something very specific and I had to
be able to demonstrate I could do it so
it wasn't it was it was a it was a hoop
to jump through to be sure the
interesting thing about this is I
believe it's ten parts are now on
Netflix and then part two is airing in
the fall yeah so I don't know exactly
what the contractual situation is but we
just finished a twenty episode season
sure and they've released the first ten
the first half of season one and in
maybe August or September or whatever
they'll release the second half of
season one so but from the audience's
perspective it's ten now and you got to
wait six months and ten then it's what's
interesting about the show I saw the
first two episodes and there's clearly a
barking storyline that's going through
these things can you sort of talk a
little bit about what the show is about
and the fact that there is this
storyline that's carrying through yeah
well what Netflix has done that's so
cool is they're taking the genre and
they're bending it a little bit you know
you've you've seen over the last 15 20
years that family entertainment and
family sitcoms have a particularly
canned a particular feel lockers in the
school hallway you know just the friends
and the there's just certain tropes that
go along with those things and you can
see them in this show but they're but
that's it's not what this show is about
the heart of this show is actually the
drama so it's a multicam it's in front
of an audience but the plot is is kind
of the real driving factor and that's
not what most sitcoms are like so
basically Nick shows up on our door
upset saying we were supposed to pick
her up at the train station we're like
whoa what's going on she she claims that
her parents have died that for a year
she's been in foster care were her only
living relatives and she needed them
she's here to live with us and we have
to react to that and my I'm a typical TV
dad and I'm like sure great family come
live with us you know and the other
family arrests of the family or at least
the mom and the son are like whoa wait
do we are we ready to have like another
kid now
Laurens character Molly the daughter is
a little bit like okay you can stay in
my room and what you come to realize
pretty quickly is that she's not
actually there that she's lying she's
there under false pretenses she's
actually a grifter a scam artist who's
been trained by her foster parents on
how to steal from people so and it's not
a random family she's chosen she's
actually targeted us because she wants
to seek revenge and you learn a little
bit of that over time but you know the
storyline you're talking about is like
is she gonna get caught what are these
what is this families these foster
parents like what's their deal or is our
family gonna is it going to split our
family apart are we gonna it's it's you
know liz has her
restaurant and she's independent and
she's ambitious I'm like a bank loan
officer senior loan officer at a bank
son is very ambitious wants to be like
school president the daughters like it
just kind of like that there's turmoil
and because it's Netflix they they're
pushing the genre it's it's like how
young can they make an antihero
we're used to seeing Dexter and you know
The Sopranos and you know those those
kinds of shows where they there's people
doing bad things but you end up kind of
rooting for him you like him anyway
and so Nick is this pretty young girl
who's very you know great little actress
when she when she's trying to trick us
into her emotions but she's also under
duress you know the truth is that her
father is anyhow well you learned pretty
quickly in Episode two well you see the
guy in the end all every review is
mentioned in and all the different shows
I mentioned it but there's a guy in the
jumpsuit tell you the orange jumpsuit
calling from a prison and he's saying to
her I need money I need money now I'm
gonna I need money to get out of here
for my lawyer I need money because these
people that are after me and and so
she's sort of like been she's
manipulated by the foster parents she's
provoked by her dad who's sort of
playing a con on her she's playing a con
on us and even though we've got a studio
audience that's laughing you know
there's a lot of times where they're
like what you know you kind of like did
we lose them did we lose the audience
there and there they're hanging on every
word they want to see if she gets caught
you know they want and and some of the
drama when you hurt people it's scary
and it's sad and it's like whoa it's not
a sitcom it's a drama thriller kind of
thing so it's it's a genre bending thing
that's that's trying to be appealing to
young people and families but young
people particularly young girls who can
look up to her she's like I said she's
pretty her clothes are cool she's nice
she's smart but then she's like doing
stuff that you're not supposed to do and
what's the more
what is the moral outcome of that you
know and it's not every episode gets
wrapped up like most sitcoms where okay
the morality is reset you can start the
episode fresh this is like wait a minute
what just happened you want to see the
next episode
yeah for binge culture pinch culture
[ __ ] watching yeah I'm curious when you
get when you got the job and everything
did they lay out to you like here's our
ultimate plan we're thinking you know
ultimately where it's gonna go or it's
sort of like okay we know where it's
going in these first 20 episodes let's
see what happens they have been it's a
great question David and kiichi our
bosses the showrunners had had some time
with it it seems fast in the kind of
macro look at it but from a micro sense
they had like six seven months where
they knew they were doing it so they had
written a lot of the scripts we didn't
see a lot of them but they actually
pretty early on sat the actors down
independently they're like listen we
want you to know where your character is
going we want you to know where this is
going and they they laid it out for us
which was really helpful but then of
course an episode later you forget all
that and you're just kind of in the
moment trying to trying to figure out
how to deliver those those beats you
know as well as can be delivered you
never this is your first quote-unquote
sitcom yeah well what surprised you
about the making of a sitcom and what do
you wish maybe you knew going in if
anything well I knew a lot theoretically
about it I knew I knew I knew what the
the on paper what the rhythm of the week
is you know it's a very specific
workweek it's a it's a it's a factory
job you know Monday you do a table read
and then and then that's over and then
maybe a little bit of rehearsal but that
day ends very early then that night you
get some changes then you do a studio or
you do the the creators you get a
run-through on Tuesday the network gets
a run-through on Wednesday then there's
a pre shoot on Thursday and then there's
tape in front of the audience on Friday
you're coming later and and that's a
your nighttime experience I think you
know there's there's just some of the
technical stuff things that you that
after doing like 80 movies you'd think
would just be internalized but somehow
you know what a two shot looks like in
the four camera situation to the
director Melissa just knows it the kids
know it because they've done it before
and I've you know it took me five or six
episodes to realize if you lean on your
right that's what they're looking
and if you if that's a single and you
find the city you know just some of
those little technical things would have
been would have been good and then the
other thing you know I'm not sure that
much was surprising to me other than I
wish that I mean I I thank God for me
that I did that John Cleese play and I
learned the rhythm of the audience's
laughter and how a extra few moments of
silence can extend the laughs or that
you can read there's a kind of rolling
laughs that you can do and when to come
back in with the next line that that
thing about in comedy note being in sync
with what your audience is doing and
really pushing to let them have a good
time you know there's it's a it's a lot
less kind of there's a lot less latitude
in the sitcom world because they know
exactly what they want and your jaw you
don't have the freedom to improvise your
your you have the freedom to try and
give them exactly what they what they're
looking for so I don't know that I
didn't know that but it's just the
experience really I don't know that I
was surprised by much it but I
definitely needed episodes and you know
four or five episodes before I felt like
okay I know exactly what I'm doing here
so you're basically saying we should
watch your performance get better in
Episode six on I'd say four I say I'd
say episode I mean where this is just
friends and family right exactly yeah no
I think it's appreciably stronger
performances after episode four I did
notice in the first two you were the
weak part I absolutely for sure that was
it was definitely a problem I was easy
to be the weak link around these plan
completely F in with you you've been I
remember I was a friend in in pilot
world you lose your job all the time
they're always replacing the actors in
the pilots so you go through a whole
negotiation and you sign a thing that's
for like 37 years of your life they own
you lock stock and barrel and you do the
first table raid and then the agents
like listen they're gonna recast you
know so I think it took two or three
weeks before I was convinced that I
wasn't gonna get recast every five
seconds you know did you film this here
in LA yeah we were now
I'm not suppose I said the other day and
I got in trouble but in how in Hollywood
yeah yeah
in fact if people want to do their
homework it was on the same stages that
my little brother did the facts of life
and the Ted McGinley who plays sure one
of the foster parents Harbaugh it's the
Harbaugh's and I can't remember his
first a minute but Harbaugh's it did
married with children I did notice that
you can triangulate from that yeah it's
not hard to figure out I I know it's one
of the studio I know I'm taking a wild
stab I know where it is one of the three
places Hollywood Boulevard or sunset but
switching off that I'm curious you have
been in such movies that really mean a
lot to people when was the last time you
had to pay for a drink I often think
that if I fall I worked so hard I'm
always working I'm giving speeches I'm
going to conventions occasionally I get
to act in movies and television you know
I'm always grinding it out and I do
think sometimes like boy if if my energy
gives out and I just can't earn anymore
at least I'll be able to you know like
go from house to house like Caine and
I'm on the road and and there will be
you know that would be meals waiting for
me so I do I do that is a nice feeling
actually I would imagine in certain
sports towns it would be even more
applicable and dangerous and other ones
that's also very you've actually done
and I think you have a comic-con coming
up you've done Comic Cons that's a
hundred of them exactly what what do you
take away back do you enjoy doing those
what is it like meeting the fans who
genuinely love what you've done and the
entertainment that you've provided for
them well so just now I finished my our
shooting schedule is three weeks on one
week off and the one week is a hiatus
for the writers to get their bearings
again and work on the next coming
episodes based on whatever we've done so
during my hiatus weeks I've been
fortunate enough to do several episodes
of the Big Bang Theory and I've been a
fan of that show since the first episode
from the pilot episode just absolutely a
huge fan of that show
and what I realized when I was doing my
guest spots or what was reaffirmed for
me
is how after 12 years that show has
moved culture it's changed culture it's
empowered geeks and nerds to feel a
sense of agency and so conventions which
used to be the nerd flags are flying
high when they okay no but I mean you
know people who like science fiction
fantasy genre fare books movies comic
books whatever now they they they'll
frequent these regional Comic Cons with
their families and and it's just a much
more kind of broadly accepted
entertainment now for me I am so you
know for me it's a paid public
appearance you know I get paid to give
speeches and mental health speeches I
get I go to colleges and give speeches
of corporate speeches I'm lucky I get to
you know people I've got my degree from
UCLA history and American literature and
culture I've like I've done a lot of
things that make me kind of marketable
in the speaking world the comic-con
appearances are absolutely vital to my
experience now because you know having
been a part of some of these pop culture
phenomenon I think it adjusts kind of
the way that people in the industry
think of you in terms of what parts you
might be able to play and I think in
some ways it makes it more appealing for
people to hire you and I think in some
ways there still is a kind of bias
against that you know it took forever
for the academy to to recognize a
fantasy film for for in the account for
Best Picture and and now it's becoming a
little bit more common but you know the
corollary to that is I go to cities all
over the country and all over the world
where hundreds and hundreds thousands
tens of thousands of people will come
out and they'll stand in line to see me
or to see all you know my acting
colleagues who are there you know they
want autographs signed we do photo op
experiences we do a QA and the the
experience is the same all over the
world people who love that kind of stuff
who loved Goonies and Lord of the Ring
and even the ones who love 50 first
dates and and certainly stranger things
there's a genuine enthusiasm a patience
they like are happy to stand in the line
for a long time and they're just so
grateful when they come up and they
interact with you they just say it's
such an ego boost you know they say
thank you they say thank you for this
this movie meant so much to me you know
a lot of people who suffer from
depression come up to me and say they
that it helped them that Lord of the
Rings helped them get through a very
dark time in their life that's a common
experience there's just a whole range of
experiences that often times are not
unique but they're always powerful
they're always moving and so I'm
grateful to be able to make money to put
my kids through college
and I'm also honored that I get to come
and touch the the fans directly and
interact with them personally I am a
huge fan of Brooklyn nine-nine yeah so
let's compare cooler to be on Brooklyn
nine-nine or Big Bang Theory in trouble
joke well do you know the story of why I
was involved with Big Bang Theory uh I
don't actually know the real reason why
you got I know you've been on a few
episodes though playing just one Big
Bang sir yes yes Bang Theory no I'm
sorry I'm trying to get you to answer do
you know what the theory between what
are that what happened that maybe be a
part of Brooklyn nine-nine sorry were
you one of the people that was tweeting
positive things about it getting renewed
or is it started negative and then I
realized that it wasn't probably a good
idea to antagonize a company that might
hire me at some point in the future so I
moved it into just sort of a melancholy
plaintive wail over why Brooklyn and I
was being cancelled because I felt like
those characters and that show and that
comedy and what it was doing had earned
the right to have a victory lap and a
final season like if they were gonna
cancel it okay so shows can't live
forever but at least let them and let
the audience know that this is it and
they can wind up the characters properly
in the way they want to so that you
don't feel like you know but I wonder
what would have happened if they would
have gotten to finish that show I
thought they had earned that and Fox
canceled it so yes I was one of the
there were several of us who are known
people who are doing that do you know
who we were
I believe general del Toro correctamundo
lin-manuel Miranda yeah I've just
butchered his name which is embarrassed
and Manuel Miranda you were right you me
and I know there's another person or two
to I'm not remembering these Seth Meyers
got it yep and oh now I'm mark hamill oh
yes my grandma so we were all tweeting
away our disappointment our sadness our
rage and some fan took the guardians
from the galaxy poster and superimposed
our images on the character I was Gamora
and if memory serves and they changed
the text to say guardians of the
nine-nine and so all of a sudden they
kind of made it like a thing the
guardians of the 99 and we ended up the
five of us got on a private group chat
on Twitter you know direct messaging
each other and 36 hours later NBC picked
up the show so which I believe they
would have done anyway because the
that's who started the show and I think
they wanted it back all let's take a
little credit to you guys we it was we
became kind of ambassadors for a very
virulent campaign to have it stay on and
and so getting to act on the show was
just totally surreal I love those
characters so much I didn't I didn't ask
to be on the show I you know I didn't
call my agent and say hey you know what
we did this Guardians thing can you can
you see if they're gonna have me like I
think I earned a spot no I just I'm just
a fan of the show and and when I got the
the letter from Dan I was almost crying
I was like I can't believe I get to do
this and and sitting there you know
Andre Braugher is like he's so dry and I
just thought this guy hates me like he
doesn't know the whole nine-nine thing
and if he did I I actually felt bad when
I showed up to the set I was like you
know what I'm so sorry that we like it
became a storyline like when they got
picked up and they were being
interviewed for what was it like to go
through this process and get picked up
people were saying so I understand you
know Lin memo Miranda or Mark Hamill
Sean asked him were like you know what
do you think and they had to like
incorporate our storyline into their
you know triumphant reap ick up story I
hear what you're saying but I'm also
thinking about all the crew and all the
people that have to keep their jobs
because the show came back there's so
many times that I think people lose
track of it's not just that you have the
actor that's right it's all those people
with their jobs that's right you know
that now our you know their lives you
know what I mean and that yeah and they
and they were I mean look switching a
Big Bang Theory for a minute they're
coming up on the very there in the last
episode or two of the show the sees the
series finale is coming up and that's 12
years you know we on this show we just
finished our 20th episode and we were
all heartsick it was sad you look at the
crew like you know a lot of them are
gonna go on to whatever the next show is
but they don't know yet what its gonna
be and if the show was to get picked up
then that we want the same crew back
because they're like family with them
now so I can't imagine what 12 years of
saying goodbye to a crew is and what
those people are gonna look forward to
with their next show like how do you go
on to season one of some new show after
you've been on Big Bang Theory for 12
years I mean it's just it's a very it's
very emotional the TV's different than
then most you know jobs I think in the
world well I think a lot of people don't
realize you end up spending more time
with because the hours are so long when
you're making you know certain shows the
hours are so long that you spend more
time on set with these people than you
do your actual family well the great
thing is you get to go home to your
family which is not the case on a lot of
movies but it is a lot longer
particularly if you're the parents the
parents on a kids show work longer hours
because you know the the the the young
purport the young performers have a
shorter number of work hours they're a
lot to do and they have to get three
hours of school in so if there seems
that the parents are in that this the
young performers are not they come in
early and do those and then when the
kids finish their day the the older
performers you know kind of extend the
day that way so it definitely is like
okay we're we're but it's as it should
be it's as it should be completely
you've done a lot of voiceover work yet
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles yeah I mean
I looked at your list the list goes on
and on and on how much fun is it doing
that kind of stuff and because you've
made
even if you did nothing else you have a
very very long track record with
voiceover I just to hear you say that
just blows my mind because there were
many years decades in fact three decades
well I guess you don't count the first
decade but but you know from the time I
was 12 or 13 until the time I was 31 I
could not get a job doing it it's a very
tight-knit group of people the
voice-over world and if you're not in it
it's just very hard to break in and it
wasn't until I did Lord of the Rings and
we had like six seven weeks of voice
training voice coaching before we
started working on that trilogy you know
talking about the diaphragm and your
teeth and your tongue and your cheeks
and talking about pitch and and you know
just creating sounds just very basic
mechanical stuff that sounds silly but
when you really invest the time working
on it it changes how you hear yourself
which is really the ball game when it
comes to doing voiceovers they you you
can't just do what you think is working
you have to be able to hear what they're
hearing you know and when they make a
little note or a comment from the other
side of the glass the engineers or the
directors or whoever you have to be able
to respond to it and if you can't hear
yourself which was my problem it just
doesn't work so but then I came back
from New Zealand I started getting jobs
and and now for you to be able to say
you know that I've got this like body of
work that a voice acting it just makes
me so emotional it's incredible I love
it it's fun we're here in Glendale
Burbank and Glendale is where most of
the voice-over acting gets done and so
just driving over here in the car you
get that that anxiety feeling the
neurology starts hitting that you're
going to be doing and one of these one
of these shows so most of them are
wrapped up now I mean Turtles has done
Agent Oso is done micronauts is done I
don't know if Captain Underpants is
coming back Bunnicula has done all these
things that were represented you know 2
3 4 5 years of work of like steady
voice-over work are like wrapped up so I
actually can we call my voice overage
and I'm feeling a little like
you know naked right now I definitely
have to touch on stranger things
it is now still I think one of the most
popular things on Netflix the even the
episodes that have been out for a year
or whatever when you have a big role in
season 2 yeah
when did you realize he's into and only
season people know it's been on many
people if why eaten by dogs and it's not
a metaphor
when did you because season 1 was very
popular yeah from what I understand
season 2 obviously eclipsed what season
1 was what has it been like being part
of something that popular because I
would imagine you know that's a whole
new generation of people that literally
know you
just from stranger things you know it
absolutely is and and I mean I don't
know Netflix is very protective about
its numbers so I can tell you based on
traffic stranger things is it awfully
popular really yeah based on just
traffic on the site called Collider
oh and Collider yeah yeah so you guys
can observe that I can how's this show
doing right now there this I can't tell
you anything yet but long do I have to
wait I don't have patience three days
let me give you an example okay so they
had so I'm clicking on Collider in three
days and I'm gonna have a basic sense of
how we're doing no but I could say three
days just to make you happy
remember this movie they did last
Christmas called bird box yeah
okay so bird box we were covering bird
box and I didn't really know much about
the movie like I knew Sandra Bullock
whatever and we were covering a number
of articles and we I was seeing the
traffic on bird box eclipsing everything
and it was just so high and I said what
the f is this movie like how are so many
people reading all this stuff and then I
realized oh it's huge so the public is
the aggregator well know that when they
announced it like 45 or 50 million or 70
million people had watched it I'm like
oh well this explains that to Brian
because I could just see the try
something like that with stranger things
to strain I mean you know it um listen
if it wasn't for stranger things to and
me playing Bob newbie who is this loving
sweet you know want to be like stepdad
to will you know
whose so who brought such gentle energy
to Winona Ryder's character Joyce who
was suffering for with their children
and suffering monsters and all this and
it's like a nice little thing and then
he dies this heroic death you know
Netflix saw that and now I'm the dad of
a kid show I don't think there's any
kind of like miss mystery about the
journey from one to the other and I'm so
grateful for that I'm so grateful to the
duffer Brothers in terms of fandom you
know listen going number one interface
with that as these regional Comic Cons
that I go to and it's powerful it's
powerful the kids reactions and and you
know they lay out pictures like what do
you want an autograph for and there's
these like tug of wars between the
parents who want Goonies and the kids
want strange things and so you know
listen we just we just keep boxing on
and you know I love it and what can I
say you know it's great yeah I have to
touch one of my all-time favorite movies
is Goonies yeah why wouldn't it be do
you think there's been a lot of talk
over the years of like a sequel and
stuff do you think it actually ever
happens or do you think there's an
element of like that movie is so special
and so good that like not net everything
needs a sequel I mean I'm sort of torn
you don't I mean well for 20 years my
answer to that question was an
unequivocal yes there will be a proper
sequel it's not a question of if it's a
question of when just certainty well
that that's gone now I think we've
probably passed the threshold for which
you know all of us the original cast
members are right for doing a sequel but
I the audience is so powerful and so
devoted to it that it will I'm
absolutely convinced that it will at the
very least be rebooted which I would be
fine with you know I think you know if
it's if it's not as good as the original
Goonies and okay who cares it's it's out
there and whatever but but I think you
know Spielberg has been waiting for
whatever that magical mystical secret
sauce is and he just hasn't found it yet
so he hasn't pulled the trigger because
it
he just doesn't want it to be done and
probably he's so busy I don't know if he
could do it himself and you know dick
Donner wants it they wanted a musical
out of it I've always said it should be
a cartoon like a Saturday morning
cartoon you know nothing is this beloved
and this you know in demand for such a
long period of time and not getting done
it just has to get done it has to I was
going to say that for me the one
advantage of waiting this long to do it
is a lot of these sequels that have been
made now have incorporated real time to
help tell the sequel story so I was
going to say that there's actually
enough time now where a lot of the
people that were in the Goonies could
have families and their kids yeah it
could be the ones that go we've been
like that for 20 years that my
daughter's 22 it's like it could have
been that at any point I don't know man
I I just feel like it would be great to
get a call one day to say like hey would
you like to do a cameo and in
Spielberg's Goonies reboot or you know I
think it's just fast highly unlikely
that they would be like here's the
script you know you're the lead again or
you're like the co-lead there's the
whoever the young kids are and then the
old by you know I just don't Corey
Feldman and I put together a three-act
treatment for it and we pitched it to
dick Donner and it never got made but if
we pitched it to him and he the whole
time he was his eyes were closed and he
was late it was really cool well I we
thought it was great we had really
worked out and he afterwards he goes
well you guys really thought about this
like yeah we have we have what do you
think yeah we're not doing that when was
the last time you were at Notre Dame or
in that area and when was last time you
paid for a meal in that area that's
funny you're going the free meals are
important to you listen I you can't go
buy your lunch man if you need it I
gotta be honest Collider does it they do
pay me in the ketchup packets and
there's a real problem well yeah there's
a lot of sugar and the glucose is high
in the sugar pie in the know I you know
I've been I go there for politics a lot
I've been there for screenings what do
we do we do it last like the exact last
time it's funny Pete Buddha judge is
making a hell of a run right now
for the the Democratic nomination he's
raising a ton of money he's the crowds
are big every time you know Trump hasn't
gone after him yet he hasn't figured out
how to go after him I think it was last
I was there I had dinner with him and
his family so that was kind of pretty
cool I'm actually you remember the exact
reason it was Hillary it was I was
campaigning for Hillary Clinton it was
he's very he has impressed me with what
he has said and done yeah yeah you know
there it's very early and our country
for better or worse and mostly worse
loves to build people up and then tear
him down so I don't know what's personal
stuff he has in his life I don't know
what faux pas is gonna happen but as a
guy who I mean you wouldn't think a
small city mayor or a mid city mayor
could be the president United States but
the only requirement in the Constitution
is that you'd be born in the United
States 35 years old that's I think those
are the only two is there a third one
no I think those are the two you got it
yeah and he satisfies both those he did
you know that he I'm not even promoting
him I haven't it like Senna who I
support or not but you're just watching
this phenomenon unfold and you sort of
think wow could could this little guy
he's literally short and when I say
little I just mean physically he's short
he's a hobbit you know with this goofy
name he's gay he's married and you just
think is that the guy who could take
down the the ugly American and maybe he
could I just think that so interesting I
I don't want to open the door on
politics yes obviously I feel like you
do yeah I will just say that I get
nervous I think that his message and
what he has said has been great I get a
nervous that that the country is a lot
more racist and a lot more closed-minded
than I thought that they were you know I
would say that that enough of the
country is racist and close-minded that
it can swamp the conversation I don't
know that a majority of the people are
racist but it's it's people who aren't
racist need to speak up louder and
clearer completely I think that I think
it is important as ever I was
particularly in the south I've made a
couple of movies in the south for our
three movies in the South in Birmingham
Alabama
- and Birmingham was the other one I did
one in Florida I guess that's
psychically in the south
my ex stranger things is filmed in
Georgia and the people I know they're
the working people I know they're that I
visited with our good decent people
they're not racist at all but boy the
the the region puts out an energy and
they need to they need to be figure out
how to combat that image that gets sent
out completely listen I could do
politics for thirty minutes because I
don't know I don't want to get you in
trouble I did it I did a Twitter pause
on politics to relay so that my energy
towards the family show would not be
co-opted but you asked where I was last
in Southland completely answer as I was
there campaigning for Hillary Clinton
and in 2000 anyone but Trump I'll say it
like anyone but Trump so wrapping up
with you I just have a few quick things
what TV show do you want to guest star
on oh my gosh I would have said big bank
there and Brooklyn nine-nine so uh but
now oh gosh my daughter has me watching
Gilmore Girls but that's over so I can't
beat Gilmore Girls
I've actually people say shows that have
ended yeah so yeah West Wing yeah there
we go
what other show what our shows are out
there right now um his new girl going
away that's been off now yeah the new
girls off hundred percent off yeah I
guess we're see there you go all the all
the old shows I guess I don't know my
dream came true the two that I are my
favorites I got today you won the
lottery with that without a doubt what
TV show have you watched all the way
through more than once like series yeah
well friends in West Wing I've gone
through all seasons more than once
willing grace sure these all work by the
way that's true what else we knew well
new girl except I'm not all completed
How I Met Your Mother
nope yeah that one we've watched all of
those I have probably cheers I think
I've hit every cheers episode I'm just
naming comedies except for a West Wing I
see what you the priorities at home are
comedies well we the it's our family
bonding we actually really that's you
know we the kids aren't outdoor kids
that much
we you know that's our that's our Jam
sure we want and we I think we've let
our kids watch programs that might be a
little inappropriate
agent appropriate so but well that's
just we just love those shows and that's
how we are with our kids but but this
show is by all the measure all the
people who you know tell you whether
it's appropriate for families it scores
very well you know on all the categories
I think once or twice we drink wine when
we're away from the kids so that's like
a little bit of a thing for some people
but but now it was almost drink wine in
the second episode or maybe you do drink
some wine in the second episode it's on
it's open on the table yeah it's open on
the table yeah nothing wrong funny it
was it was a discussion with Netflix and
with the creators of the show and their
attitudes like no we want this to have a
real feeling and we don't want to talk
down to families and obviously you know
if you watch Big Bang Theory she's got
that wine and every he's seen
practically so but no I mean this is we
they try and reflect a little bit of you
know these are working you're successful
working people and that's what that's
real life yeah listen I could go on and
on but I'm just gonna stop there and say
I really mean it thank you so much for
coming in studio thank you for having me
and I really hope the show is a huge hit
and you you're welcome back I'll only
know based on what you tell me is
Collider yes tell me about class so
quiet come on let me interview for what
is Collider we have at least five
readers a month we have ten readers on
video but readers how many journalists
are there oh we have a really big staff
action really yeah like 30 people no no
we have like seven full-time on the
website right um and there's a lot of
people that work here and on the video
side okay and start what's your job I'm
editor-in-chief of the website you are
editor-in-chief of a liner I also saw
taking you away from your core duties
for like a half hour I'm actually sick
collapsing somebody asked if colliders
collapsing out there I actually started
the site in July when we went live in
July of oh five and it turned in my
bedroom and it turned into all this
congratulations it's a pretty great boy
yeah you know yeah awesome well I really
appreciate letting me come in please
I really mean it big fan of yours I'm
super happy you came thank you so much
really